welcome to the barracks asst mega panel
for sid meier's civilization beyond
Earth my name is chris waters I'll be
the moderator today uh usually i'm
writing or hosting videos or whatnot and
making a goofy smile gamespot com I'm
not gonna be the one doing most of the
talking it's gonna be these four to my
right so I'm gonna let them introduce
themselves and without further ado let's
start with you Lena sure so my name is
Lena bank I'm the lead producer i'm
anton stringer I'm the gameplay designer
I'm well Miller I'm the co-lead designer
I'm David McDonough I'm the other co
lead designer we announced this game at
PAX East and we're just shocked some
people were there I'm sure so thank you
this we said the same thing at PAX East
but this game is really for you like our
fans are our biggest asset and we are so
happy that you're here and thank you
very much for coming out today we really
appreciate it
you guys have been co designers on games
before and have been really working
together as a team for a long time can
you give us a little insight as to how
that came about and sort of what
launched you guys on the path to beyond
Earth yes co-lead designers David and I
are a creative team but more so I think
the whole the whole team contributes to
the the creative energy and direction of
this game but the two of us met in
college way back when and I didn't like
him very much when I met him the first
time he had this funny hat on which he's
probably carrying with him right now but
we share classes together and started
making games together and went through
college learning to do that and through
lots of luck and some perseverance
landed it for axis at about the same
time and here we are today it's it's a
really special thing to be here once you
landed at Firaxis you guys have worked
on some games there before together but
beyond Earth sort of for a long time
even before he started development on it
was something you guys had in mind we're
kind of angling for how did what what
set you on that trajectory yeah so
before we got to do this game we made a
mobile game called haunted hollow which
was a lot of fun and while we were
making that game were sort of whispering
in some years around at Firaxis for the
idea of doing a sieve in space which
like like many of our fans we've been
wanting to see for access do for quite a
long time we both grew up on the sieve
series civ 2 and alpha centauri we're
two of my first sivs and so I'm like
among the ranks of our allegiance of
fans who were saying please for access
can you make this one again and
eventually once again sort of by sheer
luck the the circumstances aligned and
the company directors came to us and
said you know that game you've been
talking about we might have an
opportunity to do that and you know
without without my opinion really
earning it or deserving it at all we we
became leads of the new idea of sitting
the future which turned into beyond
Earth so we couldn't be more grateful or
more police that it was that fell to us
to get to do this thing we've been huge
fans of this idea and really
enthusiastic about it ever since we came
to for access ever since we started to
play games so
it's really a dream come true to make
this game feast your eyes on the
gameplay action here and guys take it
away so what are we looking at now is
bit more mid to late game if you follow
the coverage we've been doing so far we
saw a lot of early game but we wanted to
share some more late-game fun with you
and the effects and stuff and gameplay
systems we have in the game here one of
the things you'll also notice is the
fungal biome and so since I have
gameplay designers and designers with me
I'll just let them talk about the
gameplay system they implemented each
and while we go through and actually
look at it in action yeah so Lena
mentioned the fungal biome here we've
shown off to biomes already the the lush
biome which is very terrestrial the arid
biome which looks like something
straight out of Frank Herbert's dune and
this one which is I think the most
bizarre and strange of the environments
that you can play in and this the the
biome is just one of the aspects of our
map generation system underneath that or
the map scripts which we've written to
make really interesting gameplay
environments for you to play in and
those are also moddable so we're really
excited to see what our team can do
there but we're also playing a purity
sieve here a purity affinity oriented
sieve so we can walk around the map and
kind of explain what's going on here so
one of the things that you're seeing is
we're playing as Brazilian and we've
already started to improve our landscape
one of the big things about the purity
affinity and actually their victory type
the promised land is about making this
new alien planet into a sort of new
earth a new place for Humanity to thrive
in the way that it was originally
intended and so we have a lot of farm
lands going across here in between our
capital of Citadella and Manuel and kind
of beneath the row that we have gone
there we also have some terror escapes
which are some kind of weight game
improvements that are really cool yeah
the terror escapes are sort of hard to
maintain but they're they're sort of the
best the absolute best improvement you
can have and purity likes them a lot
yeah so we're bringing a little bit of
Earth and the genetics that we came with
on our spacecraft and where we create
here on this very alien planet so
growing actual trees instead of just
giant mushroom trees yeah that's right I
think we also have a solar collector in
orbit over our city just about to be
launched actually yeah so we we have a
solar collector built here the orbital
air system is one of the really fun
things that's new and very different
from historical civilization games so
we're launching it over our our farms
and our hills there outside our of our
capital what that's going to do is
that's going to increase our energy
output of those tiles and it's going to
stay in orbit for about 50-60 terms and
then it's going to crash down it might
create a crash satellite salvage that we
can go and pick up for some extra
resources but the the solar collector is
really useful for maintaining your
economy and of course there's other
orbital units as well you don't have to
just have peaceful ones there are some
military minded ones ones that let you
transport your units and kind of
backdoor attack an enemy that you don't
like very much once that all barred
you'll see some of those a little later
anything that there's one that's coming
up so another system that is really fun
is the virtue system so we've just
accumulated enough culture in order to
develop the virtues of our civilization
and this some of you sue five players
may recognize this is sort of similar to
the social policy system but it behaves
much more like a like a skill tree about
RPG character so there's these four
categories of virtues that you can
develop and these represent kind of sort
of philosophical attitudes government
choices that your people make on this
new planet and it's independent from
what technologies you do what affinities
you do so you could have a very my
supremacy focused sieve or you could
have a peaceful prosperity growing
supremacy soup so the four categories
across the top are might prosperity
knowledge and industry and they each
kind of have a different gameplay focus
they each make you stronger in different
ways and in addition to choosing what
category you want to emphasize you can
also choose whether to kind of drill
down in one category like I really like
knowledge i'm going to get all the
technology all the culture or you can
kind of spread wide as we've done here
so bonuses in the rows or in the columns
like it once you reach a certain
threshold you'll get it you'll get a
kicker bonus and those are some of the
most powerful bonuses in the game so
are really worth shooting form so we
have enough culture probably the way it
looks like we are just about to get in
our next synergy bonus and the knowledge
tree if we get one more so we're gonna
go down to the bottom there and choose
techno artisans which gives us extra
science based on our culture outputs
which is synergizes really nicely with
what we're doing and the bonus will give
us ten percent science in our city which
is really awesome so we're going to do
that when anyone here consider
themselves a techno artisan no all right
we got one of that one back there so
this is one of our most favorite systems
one of the new ideas for the game is the
the web-based technology the central
radial style design and in this game
about midway through we've gotten a fair
few our frontier is pushed out sorta to
the fringes where things start to get a
little more sci-fi a little more extreme
so one of the one of the branches that
we've made our way out to so far is
planetary engineering which represents
kind of like the furthest you can go
along the terraforming path to where you
can riorca tech to the planet itself
just to an extent and it provides a
number of really interesting specialty
powers one of them is access to a leave
tech for the purity affinity called
seismic conduction which lets you build
the Archimedes lever which is a massive
building size wonder that is a basically
it's a tectonic weapon attacks units
that approach the city through by
pounding the ground underneath them
effectively and so that's just one of
I've almost two dozen sci-fi wonders in
the game that are sort of designed
around this style of they represent
really elaborate imaginary extreme
expressions of all the various ways that
you could deepen your technological
advancement so planter engineering in
the terraforming text lead to you know
nice domestic happy things like the
solar collector but also hideous
powerful devastating things like like
the Archimedes lever and so you can pan
up a little bit you can see some of the
other options places we didn't go yet
but could transgenics and artificial
evolution swing up higher up and see the
more harmony style text like so excuse
me you haven't gone quite far like
they're there there's designer life
forms which lets you make the rocktopus
among other
did you say rocked I did say R octopus
if you watch the first for access
livestream you you hopefully were
treated to an extensive explanation by
Anton where that name came from I
thought someone would change it and no
one did it's yeah this week we want a a
floating air unit that's pretty good
Harvick harmony would use in the way
game we're thinking elegant dragons
would be cool but it's not like we want
something really needs we're like what
if there's just this floating jellyfish
octopus thing and it uses the float
stone there's one of the resources of
the game do just kind of float above the
earth and uses its tendrils to kind of
get rather food from the bottom and so
it's kind of like genetically engineered
awesome unit and its really interesting
too because if it's actually a horrible
unit so it kind of floats along the
ground doesn't really do anything but
can transport to the front lines then it
kind of flutes in the orbit and can spew
acids yes it's very powerful and because
it's an orbiting unit like you know
other guys have a really tough time
shooting back and then when you're done
with it you can the rock to post floats
back down normally the satellites will
crash but the brought to pittsburgh vs
back down you can reposition it you know
you know further down the battle line or
wherever you need it stop feeding right
yeah the funny part of that was that we
got pretty late in production right
about the time when localization needed
to lock down and we needed to you know
make sure that all our ducks were in a
row and Anton comes in one day he says
guys are we shipping this game calling
it the rock the post guys just just what
we're gonna call it even I feel like
yeah like yeah of course I was a little
too serious serious no you misunderstand
proc to us is a great fun and another
pun you'll notice is the technology that
it's all in is called designer
life-forms so that's mean yeah it's like
genetic design but it's also us as
designers making our favorite life
anyway anyway yeah so um so that's just
a couple tidbits of fun stuff in the web
if you swing around to the left you can
glance over a few more but this has been
a real pleasure to work on obviously
like this is one of the purest
expressions of the fun and imagination
that we got to put into this game to let
like you know what was the future going
to be one of everything they're all
crazy and silly let's have them all and
so like you know bioengineering and
biomedical eng skyscrapers augmentation
you know advanced robotics artificial
intelligence thinking computers battle
droids it's all it's all in there
somewhere yeah we can have them all then
you need to choose basically would come
stuff I'll just play the game ten times
then you can get them all right one of
the fundamental differences between the
tech tree in civ 5 and the tech web and
beyond earth is that you won't in one
play session research all of the text in
the game probably sixty or seventy
percent which is different and usually
in a civ 5 game everyone has all the
text by the end of the game so this this
does a couple things for us it it makes
the game a lot more replayable but it
also diversifies the sibs that are
playing against you so even if you play
against the same neighbor twice in two
different games they may choose a
totally different tech path and you'll
have to figure that out as you go so
it's a much more dynamic and versatile
system and we're really happy with the
way it turned out not everybody will get
the octopus right and each of the
leaders to like you know all of our
sponsor leaders they're not predisposed
to you know fielding doesn't always go
for supremacy you're always for purity
you're going to see not only you change
every time but like they've said all
your opponents will be changing too and
the leader appearances will change in
reaction to that and the cities that
they build the technologies they
research on the units to bring
battlefield so you might have fielding
you know kind of marching down you with
supremacy fronts on one game or you
might have her floating rocktopus
assault as a late-game a harmony player
in another game do you think you could
introduce us to her yeah speaking
question why do you have tropi jump into
diplomacy so I'm one of the other really
cool things we get to do on this game
that we um the no previous save is done
is make the leaders actually change over
time as their you know decisions come to
prayer on their civilization and their
identity starts to evolve so here we're
talking to Suzanne fielding leader arc
the American reclamation corporation one
of the more ruthless and power mad saves
in the game and she's going in the
Supremacy direction which you can tell
from the sort of like slate gray kind of
icy looking gear that she's now sporting
and this is one step along the path she
can get even more devoted to to this
affinity and look even more terrifying
by the end of the game but one of the
interesting things are going to get the
show off here is a new concept for the
game we're very excited about for
diplomacy called the favors system which
is a diplomatic currency diplomacy isn't
going to always be the sexiest system
and civ like you know you know like what
you know you know walk around the halls
of packs and hear people just to talk
about hey did you check out that new
diplomacy system man I totally want to
play that but it's really powerful in a
game like sieve but in the past it's
always been kind of it's been a little
hard to tell what was going on and hard
to really fold into your strategy so we
came up with this idea for diplomatic
currency called favors where you leaders
will do things for you and give you
favor or you'll do things for them and
give you favors sort of as kind of iou's
and you can bank these up and then cash
them in to make the leader do things
later on in the game up to and including
declaring war in your in your stead on a
person you don't like so you can trade
them in for you know you know resources
you know I happen to need a thousand
energy right now you owe me five favors
do it or you can like bank them up 15 16
17 favors and then late in the game when
maybe you're going to make your victory
run and you need to distract the world
population a little bit you can call up
one liter foursome declare war on
another one and just kind of like kick
over the anthill and let them all fight
each other while you go and win the game
so we've got a favor over over Suzanne
right now enough to get a few strategic
resources out of her that we might need
for some more some nifty or orbital
units things like that if you accept
that excellent so the favors idea came
from I like it was really really late in
the process it was you know she was not
pleased so Wayne is our producer she
makes sure that we don't totally go off
the rails with all our crazy ideas and
that that has to that has to be more and
more reality as we closer and closer to
ship obviously but David and I have been
ruminating on diplomacy for a while and
he came in one morning just ecstatic
because he had thought of a way to add
something cool to diplomacy the problem
was like it was after content lock it
was close to you know another major
deadline it was like we should not be
adding features to this game right now
but we did and we just didn't tell
anybody about it okay that's a small
team
luckily it turned out really well
luckily this is we knew what we were
doing sometimes well yeah we're I was
trying to describe the system I was like
um what like think of the movie The
Godfather like what was important to Don
Corleone II it wasn't you know resources
and money and thugs it was influenced
right it was the ability to manipulate
the other people and get them to do what
he wanted them to do when he wanted them
to do it and that was a one thing that
diplomacy always lacked in civil is
ability to manipulate and to make
long-term plans and then have them come
to fruition and so like all of the now
all the favors achievements are named
after quotes from The Godfather and the
link should be obvious like the favors
is not a benign system you're meant to
use it to like mess up everybody so
we've been cultivating a diplomatic
relationship with Susannah fielding
throughout the course of the game here
we've been we've established some trade
routes with her we have to trade vessels
that we've made here but there's this
what looks like an island off of our
coast and that's actually a giant alien
called the Krakken which is not is not
good for business so we've driven some
destroyers over here and we'll see if we
can't take out the Kraken so that we can
free up our shipping lanes
yeah this it's a giant land mass so
these cannons are not gonna do much
we're gonna Whittle it down here though
so we almost took it out so close
fortunately we have a couple air units
in our city ready to go see how they do
now we're talking okay so that has
cleared the shipping lane we can
continue to to a trade with Suzanne
across the pond here but she has some
other problems that we need to help her
deal with will hop over here her
neighbor is Vadim Kozlov and he has gone
hardcore down the supremacy track even
farther than Suzanne herself has and a
little earlier in the game we decided to
excavate an expedition site that was
pretty close to him and he hasn't really
forgiven us since he's the kind of guy
that holds a grudge and war is about to
break out and in the words of Pete
Murray what would a civilization demo be
without declaring war on someone so
let's go ahead and do that so you can
see that he he has gone hardcore down
the Supremacy direction he's all kitted
out with all these cybernetic
augmentation his costume is very ornate
and has changed significantly since we
would have seen him earlier in the game
but no matter we'll press forward
yeah whatever okay so one of the
fundamental differentiating
characteristics of the affinity system
here is that they represent distinctive
gameplay styles this is very important
to us to kind of build this into the
mechanics of affinities supremacy which
which is Kozlov right now is all about
battlefield positioning and tactical
geometry so the individual units are
much weaker but when combined in certain
configurations on the battlefield they
become very strong purity which we are
playing currently is sort of the
opposite of that it's raw power it's
like more guns you know big levitating
tanks right so we'll see how they match
up we need to disrupt his formation in
order to win here
now that savors really tough we've got
something for him a little later but
first let's try out the aegis the aegis
down here is a really cool unit when
he's been upgraded one more level he
gets to attack twice which makes him
great for crowd control but it would be
pretty good against these these units
here almost
okay now we still we've we've pretty
pretty well decimated the ground forces
here we still have the safer to worry
about fortunately though we've parked an
offensive orbital satellite a tactical
satellite the planet carver to help us
out so let's see what this does Oh still
didn't kill him geez okay so now we're
going to bring out the big guns in a
very literal sense this is the love
destroyer this is the sort of epitome of
of the purity philosophy on on military
might and legend has it that each one of
these things actually contains an earth
relic and if the commander doesn't bring
the earth relic back his court-martial
is very short so we'll see what this
thing does
there we go okay so we have successfully
we've successfully dealt with this
incursion by blood IAM Kozlov we can I
think march to victory with our partner
Suzanne fielding this is a very brief
glimpse into the late game of sid
meier's civilization beyond Earth it's a
it's a really really exciting game and
we can't wait for you guys to get your
hands on it
and the moment you will get your hands
on will be in October and the 24th
anybody non-american here like maybe
from across the pond it will be an
international ship date I'm German I'm
really excited about that everybody on
the whole world will be able to buy this
game on the same day
and then they will all get along super
diplomatically in multiplayer matches
alright well obviously that demo was
packed with a ton of stuff that I think
everyone here wants to hear a lot more
about so let's start with the affinity
system because that we saw that with the
you know the purity sort of how it
affected the your land management and
then with the Supremacy how even though
people who are of the same affinity they
don't necessarily get along there's it's
sort of a pervasive thing throughout all
the game elements so I guess let's let's
just start talking affinities sure the
affinity system is is cool because it's
I think all civilization games make some
philosophical statement to their players
and civilization in the past has said
you know what if what if this
combination of things were true what if
you know Gandhi had nukes or Genghis
Khan was an economic powerhouse or you
know these there these kinds of
scenarios that you set up and sieve and
what this game asks is what is next like
given a thousand years from now what do
we look like who are we do we even
resemble the human beings that we are
today that so that's the question that
this game poses and we when we develop
the game early in its design came up
with three very evocative answers to
that question harmony purity and
supremacy harmony is about becoming
indigenous to the new planet we were
sort of destructive on Old Earth we want
to become more like the indigenous life
that's already there and this doesn't
mean space hippies or anything I mean
you know your harmony player can be can
be checked up and pretty militarily
vicious so not the Navi is what we're
getting at not necessarily anyway and
then there's supremacy which says we
want to be planet agnostic we don't want
the planet to determine our destiny
anymore we're going to change our
physiology we're going to augment
ourselves with machines so that we can
live anywhere and it won't matter and
then purity which i think is the most
interesting is a rejection of both of
those and this this is kind of comes
from a lot of inspirational places
canticle for leibowitz is is a big one
but it's like they really venerate
Old Earth in a way that none of the
others do almost to a religious
fanatical degree and they reject both of
these these these other solutions they
say we want to keep ourselves pure we
are not going to change our biology
we're not going to augment ourselves
with with machines we're going to build
the biggest guns and we're going to
change this planet into Old Earth and
that's their approach so you can see how
the diplomatic landscape could be
colored by this the military landscape
can be colored by this it's a
fundamental change to the way civ works
is and is unique to be on earth so the
that's a really good description of like
philosophically what it would be what
you would think emotionally would be
like to play these things but we're also
really excited to tell you about how
they actually play and what you how's
your game is going to be like if you're
playing as one of these affinities are
playing against them so just just start
on the end harmony players because of
their emphasis on sort of becoming
symbiotic with the planet they have
their very growth heavy they have a lot
of advantages of the game from the
natural landscape from the terrain they
had a lot of territory they have I think
the biggest tool box or how to deal with
the aliens it's an interesting question
we get a lot that harmony doesn't always
necessarily mean that you're friendly
with the aliens at least not all the
time it just means that you're you're
able to manipulate them until a great
much greater degree and tolerate their
presence to a much greater degree than
any of the other sim so you can leave
them alone and eventually to get
friendly status with the aliens quicker
more easily and then the natural things
that benefit the aliens like like my
asthma which is the sort of alien ish
the fungal gas that covers the planet
that's really bad for you when you first
land if you're the harm a player you can
eventually make that your your friend
you can make it so that you heal in my
asthma just like the aliens do you move
faster through the terrain like the
aliens do you start to learn the lessons
of the planet incorporated into the way
your SIB works so it's in your interest
for instance to grab lots of planetary
surface to leave it relatively intact
and or improve it very intelligently not
to antagonize the aliens too much
especially if you want to use them as
sort of like a proxy army late in the
game and but definitely to like sort of
steer clear of the
the more invasive tactics of the the
other two affinities and whatever you
were too if you were to bump up against
them to do what you can to keep them
from over running your territory or over
running the surface so that you don't
have room to grow and none of room to
expand um you guys want to talk about
well actually before we head on to the
other affinities I want to clarify
something about aliens because you sort
of you land on a planet you're starting
your Sid it's tempting to think of
aliens as barbarians and to sort of
treat them in the way that you've
treated them in passives but I think you
guys saw from the crack in that aliens
are a whole different breed and a whole
different kind of entity you're gonna
have to tackle yes very much so yeah you
want to go ahead yeah aliens are
definitely very different than
barbarians and we've seen sip five
players really good sir five players
jump into this game and play just like
they played so five with barbarians and
it didn't always turn out so well
basically what happens is that you
notice the aliens are getting more
hostile towards you and at some point
they call in the bigger brothers let's
say yeah significantly stronger than we
can deal with so the cravings one
example you might have seen the siege
ones in earlier coverage so once those
things are closing in on your cities
because you messed up all the alien like
the small aliens around you you're in
pretty big trouble so yeah it's
basically a decision for you do you want
to take them on and deal with the
consequences or do you want to try and
avoid them which isn't always easy
because they're kind of annoying they're
all around you and you might want to get
rid of them because there's this juicy
spot in that forest right outside your
borders that you want a city but there's
an Alienist so you see these one of the
most interesting things I find what I'm
playing a game about it is that the
aliens often occupy what we call kind of
internally wild areas it's actually
something that
generator uses it kind of generates
these alien heavy areas that are not
just full of hostile life forms but also
full really rich resources and great
land so it's not a great site for your
your first city but once you know
especially we're going military early on
you can take take out an alien nest
clear it out from aliens and you have a
really strong foundation for another
city but you have to risk pissing them
off a whole lot we can backfire Yuri
fallout that have them on us it's
awesome yep glorious for you mean well
of course different affinities will have
different approaches to aliens harmony
of the most sort of distinctive but we
were just sort of getting a look there
at the unit differences between
different affinities the way that your
civilization evolves to look so
substantially different we saw it in the
the portraits of the leaders we saw it
in the unit's themselves can we talk a
little bit about one of the other sort
of get into maybe supremacy a little bit
and sort of chart maybe a course for how
a Supremacy based civ would go about
their business supremacy is all about
for excite and superconductors and fast
computers and their cities take on this
very interesting angular look kind of
like path of least resistance you know
why circuit boards look the way they do
it's all path of least resistance and so
their cities start to take on this very
ominous almost dark sleek look and with
these kind of yellow accents from the
from the frack site that they use but
it's not just the cities that change its
your units that change as you upgrade
them through the unit up grading system
your leaders change we saw LOD I think a
couple slides back depending on how
they're adopting different affinities so
it's this aesthetic change to accompany
the really significant mechanical
differentiation between the sibs yeah
and there is a there was a picture
earlier of the carrier the naval carrier
and how it how much change
space don't need to be phineas and this
is something that's common to most of
our basic units even the soldier that
you start with there was some on the
battlefield in the demo and they had
changed to look very purity and they had
adopted the purity technology and that
actually plays differently than a marine
that took the harmony technology and
incorporated that into itself so you
know the harmony units will take
advantage of stronger miasma i'm looking
through the terrain the stuff that dave
was mentioning whereas you know the
other units will behave differently
supremacy will have a lot of battlefield
bonuses for being next to friendly units
targeting this far away purity is about
raw strength and shooting they have more
ranged units than the other affinities
they can kind of like bombard from very
far away with as many guns as possible
the units here so you know the the
harmony carrier once once it gets
upgraded will actually heal the
airplanes that are stationed there so
you can kind of make a strike and they
will you can kind of weight if returns
for them to heal up because harmony is
very good kind of healing their own
units and taking care of a lot of
numbers or is this a primacy carrier
will actually boost the air strike range
of the of the planes that are stationed
there as well so like you know you can
kind of make more surgical strikes
forever inland if you're playing
supremacy we call that guy the Star
Destroyer for the triangle shape it
sounds apt all right well let's in terms
of you talking about affinities and sort
of where a trajectory can take you you
know way down the line how what sort of
tactics are involved that puts me as a
sieve sort of strategist in mind like do
I need to I behooves me to choose one
right from the get go right and just
dedicate myself purity the whole way but
that's also kind of a limiting way to
play the game if you're just
automatically making every decision
based on I want this in this affinity
it's it's a valid way but you guys are
it seems like you're doing stuff to sort
of make it not so deterministic make it
not a choice you make at the beginning
and that's it yeah it's sort of half and
half I'd say and this is another kind of
statement as game designers that we're
making about how humanity can adapt to a
new world but you can research
technologies in the tech tree hardcore
that will drive you into the direction
of one of the of the affinities
regardless of what your environment is
like but it does behoove you to cater to
your setting because it
very hostile planet and if you don't
kind of analyze that early and make make
good decisions early you're going to be
fighting an uphill battle and the game
is kind of intelligent about that one of
the other ways that you get affinity
level and points is through the quest
system and at a certain point the quest
system says okay you're no longer trying
to figure out which affinity you are
you've dedicated yourself to one we're
going to reinforce that with quests that
that bolster that so that the game
systems are sort of intelligent about
when you're sort of trying to figure it
out and when you've decided in addition
to the the quest that sort of increase
your gameplay devotion to the affinia
they also flesh out a narrative of
what's happening to your people like
there's a there's a Supremacy class
called solid state citizen and there's
it tells like if you take the time to
reboot actor even if you don't you kind
of like get this sense and you know we
dress both but you get this sense of
like what's happening your society on
the fundamental level and like you know
you see the city's changing as you
change your affinities it's not just
your units almost outfield it's your
everyday people the people that are
working on farms the people that are
working your improvements the people
that are running the government and like
what's happening to them how are they
changing how is humanity changing this
cool hmm well I'm not as a whole because
similar to the way the quest system
responds to what you're preferring to do
the AI will similar will also respond
and there are some there's some tail
winds and the systems to make the a i
prefer the affinity choices that you're
not taking so that by the time the game
is over there's an interesting spectrum
of perspectives on the planet and when i
use the phrase interesting spectrum of
perspectives what i mean is there's a
lot of conflict like people are not
getting along anymore the stakes really
rise over the course of the game and
this is really expressed through one of
the things we like the most which is all
of the victories have been totally
redesigned and three of the five our
affinity devotion victories so when you
have like killed your affinity and
devoting yourself all the way the end it
comes along with this sort of epic quest
that last for the whole game that
results in this one gigantic final move
where you build this planetary wonder
it's a wonder that's so big it takes an
entire tile the city has to pick a plot
and it's working radius and put it there
and it is a city-sized building it's
it's own combat entity other armies can
come in and blow it up you have to
defend them yeah you have to defend it
it's very delicate but you build it and
then you use
it to win the game so by the end of the
game every sip on the plan is trying to
set up their victory attempt and it was
just like strife and tension and
disagreement all over the place so it's
not it's not very easy to play a
peaceful conclusion to sieve beyond
Earth because really what you're
competing to do with the other says is
just decide who's right about who's
going to what humanity is going to be
now if you decided that humanity is
going to be Robo people with their
brains uploaded into machines somebody
across the planet has a different idea
about that and won't only one of you can
be right so when you when you set up
your victory temp they're setting up
their victory tempt the AI is going it's
going to make sure that sort of one of
everything is tried and you have to win
the game by simultaneously progressing
your own and forwarding there's which is
where things like favors can come in
handy but also you know a lab destroyer
or two might be efficacious at that
moment yeah and just as like a like
morning I think the coolest examples is
in the gameplay demo we just showed we
were playing the purity kind of approach
and you know fielding and close love
were both supremacy if we had played
that out to the end game and we were
going for our purity Promised Land
victory what we would be trying to do is
build a working to bring people from
Earth weary establish contact with earth
we bring earthling settlers to this
means planet that we've prepared for
them and we start settling the new
planet you know here's the new earth
we've cultivated for you and like we are
the new humanity on this planet
supremacy on the other hand is also
building a warp gate but they're
building it to send people back to earth
in order to emancipate them from their
organic meat bodies so those two
approaches aren't really compatible in
Webster problems even fielding our good
trade partner probably wouldn't like us
at the end if we're not careful I think
that's one of the most fascinating
things to sort of to think about when in
a development process of beyond Earth is
the way that you guys are sort of
tracking that trajectory from early game
too late game and how it's spanning
centuries because you don't have the I
don't know if I'd call it a luxury but
the existing framework of human history
that starts in the you know Bronze Age
and ends up with the Internet to sort of
frame the whole thing and so through
affinities through
changing the terrain and the way they
all your units are your you're visually
showing and then through the tech web
your your charting path through science
it's it seems like that has been
basically the core challenge of this
entire game is to sort of set out those
boundaries now that you don't have that
historical basis to go on that's very
true it was very challenging we have a
really experienced team that is so good
at charting history and now they got to
apply that knowledge and that skill they
all have to discover the future of what
they think will happen so it was very
challenging because it's just you can't
go on Wikipedia and just look up what
those things will look like in a few
hundred years but on the other hand was
also hugely exciting we obviously have a
lot of sci-fi fans at the studio and
they were just like oh god we get to
make up stuff and like just make up
robots and makeup like mutated things
and so there was huge excitement and
some challenges definitely um on the
outside obviously but I know the the
designers had the same approach where
they were like okay we can do all these
things now we probably couldn't do in an
historic safe because this didn't really
happen on earth so it's like wouldn't
quite fit they're not going that
alternate history and civ usually except
for sometimes scenario scenarios it's
really like civilization are actually
all for access games really are all
based to some degree on on myth like a
cultural myth that we have so even XCOM
has little gray men and flying saucers
and you look at our other games like
pirates and railroads and civilization
all of these things are built around
sort of built in cultural knowledge that
we can leverage to deliver things for
gameplay reasons like we need exposition
we need context and we need heuristics
to help the player navigate an otherwise
very complicated gameplay space and as
designers this is one of the hardest
things for us to do because we had to go
back and invent something that at the
same time was accessible and
approachable to people but also met
the expectation of awesome sci-fi and
that was a tricky balance to strike and
it we did so by sort of incremental
progress so you kind of start in a
conventional place and work your way out
to more elaborate places more sci-fi
places in the tech web and in other
parts of the game and we also wanted to
build a narrative system that didn't
trample on the player's ability to tell
their own stories that's one of the
magical parts of civilization and
strategy games in general is just to be
able to be this procedural storytelling
engine for you and we needed to get our
context in there our exposition in there
without compromising that and that was a
challenge for us but I think we've done
it and one of the neat ways you guys
have done it knife I've played about 70
turns of this so far so very early game
but right from the start that quest
system you mentioned kicked in and you
know as sort you sort of think of a
quest you sometimes think of it as I
gotta go you know investigate this area
or explore something there's a sort of
destination but a lot of these quests
are really just little decisions that
you're making about hey this scenario
came up imagine what that would be like
how should we deal with it and you talk
a little bit about sort of where that
sort of writing comes from how it helps
you build your narrative and you know
the little gameplay boost kickers that
you sort of incentivize with any put
anybody play this old game called
actraiser anyway play this yeah you
remember the original actraiser when
like you're the you know humans on the
ground would come and like beg you for
things like please please help me with
this decide it's kind of like that
there's some quests that are kind of
like that where there's small choices
that you make and each choice is good
like there are no bad choices each
choice is good but it specializes your
civ it ornaments your civ with these
little bitty bonuses down the way and
gives you a little bit of insight into
what's going on in those cities or
what's going on in those improvements a
window into a part of civilization that
we traditionally have not explored
before which is what happens to the
little people that your your civ has
right so they're those kinds of quests
and then and then they're much
rander ones like Anton mentioned the
solid state citizen that's one of a
series of very long quest chains or the
victory quest so they're all there and
it's a system that serves a lot of
purposes it serves to teach the game to
new players it serves to deliver this
narrative content and it also serves for
you know to specialize your sim to make
the Civil even if you're playing the
same sit with the same loadout you can
make different quests and that'll
that'll be different every time you play
so it's another axis of choice one other
system that I know Anton has been
dreaming about while working on specific
spansion was the orbital later yeah
that's right so the orbital air is
basically for those of you familiar with
civ 5 it kind of breaks the one unit per
tile rule like so 65 has a lot of really
interesting tactics because military
units can only have one on pile at a
time move them around shuffle them
around but the orbital layer is a really
interesting concept because we again
because we're starting from science
fiction not from history we can say well
you know what if there's satellites just
hanging out above the planet from pretty
early in the game you can find a
resource pod on a map while you're
exploring turn 5 to 10 and it will have
an intact solar collector the basic
economic satellite if you saw in the
demo and you can launch it over your
city you can launch it over someone
else's city if it's an offensive one and
just having them hang out up there and
have persistent effects that are
affecting the ground below is a really
cool sort of like area of effect buff
channel that we didn't really have in
civ 5 we had regeneron's and other
things but they're kind of hard to
visualize himself over layer especially
since we're starting with science
fiction already just something that was
really cool to experiment with and
something that wouldn't be possible in
historical suit game it's also kind of a
different kind of land battle right
because once your civ is pretty well
developed your culture borders are
intact those aren't going to shift
unless there's open warfare and
exchanges or destruction of cities but
this the sort of you know only one
satellite can be covering a certain area
at one time but satellites can last like
six turns 10 turns they degrade they
fall out of orbit and so areas you that
you maybe had controlled you're not
going to have them controlled in 12
turns you got a plan for that
yeah so on the screen shot here that
kind of blue to hex radius is the is the
orbital units area of effect and it
can't overlap with the area of effect of
any other satellite so that makes for
some really interesting decisions so
like you have a miasmic repulsor there
and what that does it's a very short
term satellite you'll see in the bottom
left there's like zero out of six terms
that's in orbit but by the time it
finishes its job and it falls back to
the planet all of my asthma and that
blue area will be gone so if you're
playing purity if you're playing
supremacy for trying to expand to a new
city if you're trying to like clear out
some miasma in between you and an enemy
player it's a really great play but you
know well that's up there you can't have
a satellite that would overlap with it
so you might be sacrificing you know a
spot for an economic satellite over the
city that you have there so and you know
once the miasma propulsor comes out of
orbit it's room for you to put up
another satellite or for someone else to
put up one mirror instead so you kind of
there's this kind of like land battle
that's happening in orbit and it kind of
changes throughout the game because
there's always new things coming up and
old things coming back down all right
guys well we've got about five minutes
left and with all this sort of
imagination creativity all this stuff
that you guys are I mean making up for
the game or drawing from all these
different sources I there's been some
some strange little things that have
happened along the way and you guys have
teased me on a few of these little goofy
anecdotes but i think that the crowds
are gonna really get a kick out of these
so let's let's dive into these and tell
some strange stories from the world of
game development real quick to wrap up
are you ready Anton oh okay this is me
okay this was Halloween last year I was
I went to work one of the cool things we
do it for axis is it Halloween we a lot
a lot of co-workers that have kids David
just became a new father a few months
ago
actually happened when he was going to
e3 he had to turn around and fly back
and I had to do it by myself thanks no
III know what kid oh yeah wait it was it
was ok sorry she made sure I showed up
on time so I right so we have kids that
come in a Halloween you know around like
four or five towards the end of the
workday but before trick-or-treating
proper starts and they come around and
we set out candy for them and they come
grab it and safe retreat stuff so I was
dressed up like many of our co-workers
in costume and I was in case couldn't
tell dr. horrible which is one of my
favorite things and so I was designing
unit upgrades up a time to change like
so much since then and so there's a lot
of weird names in the background there
like my house which I can't describe I
don't know so I was just coming up I was
just like kind of spit ball and a lot of
different ideas for Queen and upgrades
that we could have and I was in costume
and we'll or Dave or someone with the
cameras at turn around and I just made a
goofy face and here i am with full of
regret regret Anton is like he's a
designer that really likes the
whiteboard so when he when he's working
hard it's like a beautiful mind you know
you just like scribbles numbers
everywhere and all this so yeah that
that's where that came from so this was
me we the you the UI artists on the team
and I this is Whitney bell and transfer
hartley have a very tight iteration loop
and we're fixing bugs and stuff in it to
submit a bug takes a little bit of time
so I just got in the habit of seeing
them emails with these images of things
that I saw and got tired of drawing on
them so I started photoshopping funny
things in there
it's ace attorney yeah so here's that 11
who's that
so delicious peroxide is one of the
strategic resources it's very name as a
funny story it's like the rocks bus
where it was one of the very first
things we rode into the game it goes
orange crystal it's a superconductor
called peroxide and there's just like we
made it all the way through the project
with nobody actually getting up the
courage to change it so we just got out
the other end and now forever it will be
4x aight but our artists were like all
right it's called for xxo make it look
like the firaxis logo we got nuts not
quite I took a wrong turn there
somewhere and now it's instead of the 44
x logo see bloomin onion we better have
those at the launch party um then there
was pre III um three threes an eventful
press and we were all prepared and as a
producer you're a bit nervous because
you get to show the game to press for
the very first time and you know there's
still a lot of stuff to do you have all
the things in your mind that still need
to be finished nothing's quite there yet
best bugs and everything so you're
really nervous but the build was tested
very thoroughly and we were ready and we
were so happy about where the build was
at and then we arrived in Los Angeles
and had everything set up and run
through the demo an hour before the
event started just to double check that
everything was working well and then um
pc games development totally bitters
side because there's so many graphics
cards and so many settings in this world
and that specific one that we had at
that event with the exact setup it not
quite um beaten wasn't quite represented
in our QA department so all of our shark
suddenly mouse attacks were staring us
in the face eyeballs and um luckily the
the journalists very ed um really
delighted denied they had a lot of fun
hunting and
in hindsight I actually find this
hilarious at the moment in time it
wasn't quite as hilarious but right now
I think that's actually really funny
screenshots oh we figured out what it
was we figured out what it was it's
fixed now mudblood yeah always happen
that's basically what's the look on my
face yes that one's actually pretty tame
the one with teeth were even worse
sometimes the teeth sometimes the teeth
would show up gross yeah I think those
are that's one of those moments where I
realize that like we had hit the big
leagues now so I think it was Josh or
Garrett or somebody's like oh hell we'll
just go by graphics cards go by all the
graphics cards in Los Angeles they were
ready to like run out the door just raid
best buy's but we fixed the problem and
yeah alright well as much as I'm sure
we'd all love to keep picking your
brains about civilization beyond Earth
for the rest of packs uh we got to wrap
up and get out of here for the next
panel so let's hit a few things before
we go we got some exoplanets Matt packed
talk about yeah yeah so the exoplanet
map pack is really awesome this is a
great incentive to get the game early
these the game will come with several
maps that are based on real exoplanets
most notably kepler-186f which is
actually named after Sid Meier it's
pretty cool so those are really fun lots
of interesting challenges there so go
pre-order the game if you haven't
already if you haven't already and also
uh board games up yes so a special
shout-out to our guys at our friends at
Fantasy Flight the ExCom board game is
playable at pax go find these guys it is
a lot of fun there's a lot of fun and
the next event coming up for xicon yeah
I'll have 4x econ is sold out
I'm kind of hoping we'll meet some of
you there may be in Maryland beautiful
Maryland and if you answer if you follow
civ games on Twitter and on Facebook
there are some tickets that will be
released i believe closer to the event
so you still got a chance to go ahead
and attend for xicon there we go all the
social media information you could ever
want ladies and gentlemen please give me
give them a big round of applause
developers of civilization beyond Earth
now I know a lot of you want to kind of
like do the like hang out maybe ask some
another question thing before just after
the panel ends but we have to run to a
live demo actually on the gamespot stage
but it's just a block and a half away at
the Metropole restaurant which we've
renamed sector G and we're giving away
food and drinks and you can come watch
the demo and maybe chat with them
afterwards if you want to so we're
hustling over there just follow us just
follow us and have a great packs
you